certaines des idées d'histoire initiales que nous
avions eues en termes de mémoire à court et à
long terme se sont
avérées assez correctes, par exemple
pendant la journée, vous collectez des
souvenirs et lorsque vous vous endormez, ces
souvenirs sont littéralement dispersés
tout au long de l'esprit et des références croisées,
nous avons pensé qu'il y avait probablement un
système automatisé par lequel les souvenirs
vont sur une sorte de bandes transporteuses ou de
pistes et sont triés d'une manière ou d'une autre et l'
équipe a visité un lieu de tri des œufs, nous sommes
ici pour réellement regarder la production d'œufs
juste  penser à eux comme des souvenirs, la
ferme d'œufs consistait vraiment à
trier une sorte de mémoire